I'm in Dubna in Russia,
the birthplace of six super-heavy elements.
We're on the NAB dish. Men deliver the Mendel life in bank loans.
[inaudible] And here I am next to the stage two of Dmitri Mendeleev.
And what I want to tell you about is the things that I've learnt in the last few
days about the chances of making the super-heavy elements
119 120.
So these are really special because they will begin the eighth period,
the eight throw of, of stable.
Before I came here two days ago,
I thought that that was real questions.
Whether or not it was possible ever to make these elements.
I now realize it's much more a technical problem.
People can see how this should be done,
but they can't quite work out, which is the best way.
So let me try and explain to you the problem,
the real success in the last few years in making elements
113 to 118 has been in the
project tale,
the light atom that has been accelerated towards the target.
And this has been the very rare isotope of calcium, calcium 48,
that has a big excess of neutrons.
The problem is that we have now got to the stage where we have
run out of suitable target materials to make element
119.
You need to have element 99 that's Einstein him is the
target because calcium 20 plus 99 makes
119.
The problem is that Einstein him is a very difficult element to
make.
If the Oak Ridge national laboratory runs a dedicated campaign to
making it, they could make 40 micrograms,
which would cost somewhere between five and $10 million.
And that would be enough to make a target that was only one and a half square
centimeters,
an area much smaller than the current targets that you use for these
experiments. So a whole new technology will have to be developed to stop.
The town gets overheating.
The other approach is to use a different project tile.
There are ideas of using either 51 to Tanium or
54 chromium and the existing targets.
The problem is that with Tanium and chromium,
the chances of the successful collision taking place
are much less than with calcium.
So you need a much more intense beam.
So there's the technical problems choosing your projectile
choosing targets, but assuming you've done that,
where on earth can you do the experiment?
And this is why it's been so exciting being here in Dona because they're
building a special new facility with a more intense beam
so that these experiments can be done. And it has a terrific name,
the super heavy element factory,
the building is built or almost built.
And the accelerator is just being assembled Brady and I were really
lucky to Yuri again this year and the person after whom element
118 was named or Gunnison took us for a
private tour round, the new facility, which is still being built.
So at the center is a huge magnet that is going to be used for the
cyclotron for the accelerator.
Irons are accelerated whichever project tail day twos
goes into the space between the poles of the magnet and there's accelerated
round and round in the spiral path from the center to the outside.
And by the time it gets to the outside,
it will be traveling at about a 10th of the speed of light.
And at the moment they've just got the magnet in place.
It weighs 1100 tons.
And at the moment they are measuring the magnetic field to make sure that
the magnet is performing perfectly before they put the actual accelerator
inside, but the accelerator should be up and running by the end of this year,
2017.
So once the irons come out of the accelerator at this huge speed,
they go into a separator,
which is rather like the switching system at a railway junction,
which can send the beam down one of five different beam lines to five
different experiments.
And that in itself is quite a huge piece of equipment,
but most exciting of all Braden,
I would take an into the rooms where the targets are going
to be
with the first visitors in this huge empty room.
And it was really quite moving to think this was where element
119 and 120 may be born. I was particularly fascinated.
They've already drilled the holes in the walls where
the beam is going to come through.
So you can look through this hole and see the atoms I
view of the accelerator, the,
what the target we'll see as the beams are coming towards it.
I think this is fantastic. It's completely empty room,
but this is the room where the new elements,
119 hundred and 20 a likely to be made.
So five years ago,
we made a video about preliminary experiments trying make
element 120 from titanium and California to Tanium
project tail, California, target, not here in Dubai, but in Germany.
The results were actually slightly more promising than
I realized. When I made that video.
It's not the sort of experiment that will necessarily give you a new
iPhone tomorrow, but on the other hand,
it will give us a lot of scientific understanding.
But the rarely important message that I and Brady they've got from this
visit is that things are really quite well on track to make
elements 119 and 120,
whether it'll be in two years or five years or 10 years, nobody can tell,
but certainly the science is there and we know where
we're going. And it looks really promising.
The two grams of calcium carbonate here, which have worth,
or at least if you wanted to buy,
it would cost you about half a million dollars.
So my hands are getting quite cold.